i'm laura ingram and this is the ingram
angle from washington tonight grocery
store shelves laid bare thanks to the
log jams at our biggest ports the cost
of renting a home or apartment soaring
energy an energy crisis made worse by
biden's climate agenda it threatens to
bring down the global economy
and now politico revealing that neither
biden or his team apparently saw any of
this coming
political peril that biden didn't see
coming is called inflation
but biden's not just asleep at the wheel
he's putting us to sleep too
i think he nodded off or i did a couple
separate times today when
biden was in my home state of
connecticut pushing his reckless
spending plan despite all the soaring
inflation
the world is watching
autocrats
believe
that the world is moving so rapidly
that democracies cannot generate
consensus quickly enough to get things
done
not a joke show the world
that american democracy works
huh what
he's already president in case he
doesn't know which maybe he doesn't know
then i went into rem cycle when he tried
his usual whisper routine
to sell the massive tax hikes
i don't think we should punish anybody
but just pay your fair share
just pay your fair share
but then ten minutes later that strange
oratorical tick resurfaced
i'm glad they made a profit
keep with the boy i mean that sincerely
but pay
your fair share
just pay a decent
portion
now bind of course took no questions he
ran off stage sprinkled the speech with
words like literally and no joke and for
real man
look in all seriousness here
what's wild about how things have
cratered is that the same media who
thought they were helping biden by not
aggressively covering his agenda and his
administration's conflicts of interest
the media have actually helped dig the
hole that biden's now standing in
same for his party leaders on capitol
hill and throw in the federal reserve
while you're at it
now not only did all of them downplay
inflation they all essentially
encouraged the piling on of more
spending and more debt the exact
opposite of what we should be doing now
and now the one democrat who did care
former treasury secretary larry summers
is speaking out
we have a generation of central bankers
who are defining themselves by their
wokeness they're defining themselves as
by how socially concerned
uh they are
well he's right about that they didn't
quite go far enough uh
biden's puppeteers deserve a lot of
blame here including chief of staff ron
claim
he's responsible and by the way that's
the same ron clayne who just revealed
what he really thinks of the pain people
are feeling from that high cost of
living
he liked a tweet calling inflation and
supply chain choke holds high class
problems what a [ __ ]
meanwhile biden is just kind of shuffled
from one lame controlled event to
another
always surrounded by his protective
press cocoon
this bunch biden's got running our
country isn't just asleep at the wheel
it's not even in the car
yesterday we discovered that mayor pete
is on paternity leave
okay no big deal i mean people take
maternity and paternity leave okay big
deal it's not like he has one of those
important cabinet positions i mean he's
only the secretary of transportation
when we have historic delays at major
ports in the united states
remember his big solution though for
addressing the jam-ups
apprenticeships
now the public considers these people
such inconsequential figures at this
point i don't think anyone really even
noticed that buddha judge has been on
baby leave since mid-august
but it sure tells you a lot about their
sense of urgency about the problems
directly affecting the american people
the working people who are really
hurting
are any major media concerned about
absentee cabinet secretaries
when they're actually in biden's
administration because when melania was
off the scene for a few days it was wall
to wall the last time we caught a
glimpse of her was on mar may 10th
there's been a lot of questions about
her surgery her time at walter reed and
now her
invisibility it was a legitimate media
story
if the first lady or or the person who's
standing in for first lady disappears
you want to know where she is now what
you should be optimistic about here is
that after 10 months of biden
common sense americans are waking up
and i want you to keep your eye on
virginia's governor's race this could be
the bellwether you've been waiting for a
new fox news poll has democrat terry
mcauliffe with just a slight lead over
republican glenn younkin
but that's not mcauliffe's only problem
according to the new york times he's
straining to motivate the liberal voters
an increasingly blue state
hey virginia
it's time to save yourselves
if you let another four years go by
under a democrat governor
you're going to see the terrible trend
lines for schools energy prices and
crime continue
look at how far also that the left
pushed newsome to go after he beat that
recall
measure where terry is going to take the
state if he's given the green light
radicals rule the democrat party don't
forget it's not bill clinton's anymore
democrats do know it is looking grim out
there in the old dominion that makes me
smile just today a loudoun county school
board member resigned and the
superintendent who allegedly helped
cover up those sexual assaults there
issued an after the fact apology
well that's nice very special but it's
only because this show and others did
the job the pro-biden media refused to
do
here's hoping this obvious of the
example of keister covering during a
tightly contested election backfires as
well